Há ngà chiến sẽ rất là những kinh nghiệm và bài học gì sau nè, tôi nghĩa tròn thứ Xà nè mà không ngay sảo
Và đây là muốn kinh nghiệm và muốn truyết các bạn cần phải nếu như các bạn muốn đưa học sớt và nằm mọi bài nhá
Điều lâu điên, nó là việc quay sòng, việc tức về mặt lý推, tôi nghĩa trong nè thì chúng ta có giang ngoài sáng của rồi, tả mời, tả mấy lắm, tảm nè thì là lý推
Hầu hết những tỏng buộc phần 1 phần 2 trong nè thì đều là lý推, chỉ có phần 3 là không có chút bài tập tình toán nhẹ nhàng thôi
Và như các bạn là mà học lý推 không sâu và không kinh nghiệm ở đâu nằm này, thì trách trắng là có bạn sẽ gây luôn khi mà có bạn làm cái cố hỏi trong nè thì cũng có tụi.
Bố tụi推 đều thì không chỉ có một cái đề thì có bạn nữa, mới tán có đều có bạn nữa, mới tán có đều có rất nhiều có hỏi, mới y lưu ở,
và là khi cho 2 cả 5 người dưới ôm hận rất nhiều,
và là khi các bạn có thể học lý tốt trong một dài lý推,
là như là lý推 trong các xe học qua, lý推 có phần tình nhẹn, hẹn tượng xe học qua,
các bạn có thể xong hai, lý thi đề học với dơ, sẽ không quyền thiết các bạn,
thì các bạn học tất tất tất trong vài chủ này của hay giống vài ngày quay nữa,
mà để theo với dơ, mình thiết các bạn phải học sớm,
của ông, mà vì cái việc tất lý kinh thúc các bạn có điều của buộc của quan sòng,
nhưng các bạn biết là trong nguyên có hỏi lý推,
là sao, có thể đề thi đề học năm 1 rồi,
thì nó rất nhiều có hỏi, nó lý kinh thức từ lắp mời,
từ nằm lắm mời lớn hệ 2, phụ vụ và làm tốt trong mình tất cả,
cho năng, và cho bạn thích trong mình bục cái năng có tốt khi có ý thi đề học,
thì nếu như các bạn mà nó tham nha vào thống có thể từ lông thì có nếu tốt,
nó năng này thì 2 cái chiến trong lớn của thấy thức ký đông đả vào các bạn,
nhưng nó sẽ có sớm từ đầu nằm rất là nhiều,
ở nhà thịt hẹt ra, hẹt ra, hẹt ra có hai lớp và lớp viーボ bộ có lớp in 2,
thái lớp lại đang học với cả những chiến hậm nó hơi lệnh nhau một chút,
là sẽ thì nếu như các bạn quan tơ mà các bạn chưa tìm là một lộ sình phù hợp
có lệnh nhớ tham ra lộ sình này của mối thầy,
là chờ, năm nay thì cũng là mối xử ám đế phục của mơ,
nó là thử xếp ở bên dân lạnh là nhiều người thử dụng hậm,
để làm sao 3 3 có cái đề để học năm 1 rồi,
với những xún tìm mới nhá năm 1 rồi, là chờ,
và nếu như các bạn muốn mơ mề bộ thầy để thấy ôn đệ trúc của bạn trong ký thi hậm,
nó sẽ nhắn tình trực tiếp về hói xanh, thì nó tình trường viê còn là hói lệ,
thì có có lình trực tiếp từ hình chói là nhanh kéo và lớp thục xong tình trực ra,
bắt đầu hạp luôn nhá!